alright guys bang bang I've got special
treat for you I have a gym here with us
so I appreciate you taking time to do
this thank you thanks for having me
for sure let's just jump right into your
background maybe you can give us a quick
overview of what you did in the past and
then the business you've been running
for last 20 years or so all right well
in the beginning there was light and I
graduated from Marquette University in
1984 so maybe we could talk Big East
basketball a little bit later on because
that's kind of my passion right now once
New York worked on Wall Street was there
at first Boston during the 87 crash kind
of giving some people an idea of how
freaking old I am right now 1990 came
back to Chicago working for a brokerage
firm called arbor research and training
which is a fixed-income brokerage firm I
still with them to this day they are my
marketing partner I spun myself off in
April of 98 so I've just had my 22nd
anniversary as an independent research
firm Bianco research would put out a lot
of research and the macro space politics
demographics that kind of stuff it's
more suited for fixed income people but
not exclusively fixed income people have
a number of equity types and a number of
other types that like to hear what we
talk about so we cover a lot of
different things as well - I live in
Lincoln Park I can walk to Wrigley Field
because everything in my life revolves
around something related to sports I'm
glad I wore the Yankees cap to a record
this then if you're a die-hard Cubs fan
yes yes you're the evil empire but we'll
go to that day another look on that
later
absolutely so let's just start with kind
of a 10,000 foot view of how you
currently evaluate where we are on the
economy side right just if you had to
give kind of a two minutes this is
what's happening let's start there and
then we can get into some of the nuanced
views and research that you've put out
recently yeah so we are undergoing the
most significant event of this
generation right now the the virus came
upon us
without anybody knowing about it it's
going to have I think long-lasting an
impact the wishful thinking on Wall
Street is we're just going to sit here
and talk to each other and zoom for a
little while and then it's going to go
away and it's all going to be January
2020 again once we go back we'll get
back most of the way but when I can get
back all the way I think there's gonna
be some long-term changes there's going
to be something Lobel ization but I
think we're going to look at this period
just like we talked about pre-war
post-war pre-crisis post crisis there's
going to be a pre virus post virus
period and what financial markets have
been doing is transitioning to a post
virus period that it's going to be
different I don't want to see bad or
worse because I don't think that it's
going to be different and and it's not
going to be like it was in January it
might be better in some respects and it
could be worse in other respects but I
think a better description of it would
be different elaborate on that a little
bit right this idea that it could
actually be better in some cases but
worse than others maybe give us a couple
of examples of each one of how you're
thinking about that yeah I think better
is that there's going to be more
efficiencies when it comes to work at
home and it's going to be with you know
online shopping one of the things that I
think is is they know we've been kind of
the big hope is people have the ability
to work at home but too many people are
oh yeah I'd like to work at home but I
don't know how to set this stuff up but
now they've been forced to learn how to
do it and now that they've learned how
to do it I'm hoping that and I'll put it
in virus terms I'm hoping that in the
post virus period we're going to get to
a period where if I have the sniffles if
you have the sniffles stay at home and
you turn on zoom and you don't come in
and cough on me or I don't come in and
cuff on you and get everybody sick if
your kid is sick they stay at home and
maybe their classroom now that they've
learned how to do it is being streamed
and that in the future we're going to
you know we're early on in the virus we
talked about 30,000 people die a year
because of the flu maybe that number
goes down a lot because we wash our
hands and we stay away from each other
sick and that subsequent flu seasons are
a lot less painful for the economy than
we've seen in the past now on the worst
side is to get to the markets where we
were and get the economy where we were
there was a certain amount of
aggressiveness that we had borrow buy
back your stock you know relocate to
like China because it was more efficient
go go go go go that attitude might
change a little bit now we're not going
to be as willing to borrow and lever up
that the battlecry of the wealth manager
that fear of missing out there is an
alternative FOMO atima that I think
might fall off the wayside for a while
as well too and so that kind of
aggressiveness that helped get us to the
SP 3400 level and the belief that we
were going much further than that that
may take a while to return before we
were ready to engage or embrace that one
more time yeah and it made me comment a
little bit I know you've done a lot of
work on kind of the feds action so far
you know how do you currently grade what
they've done good bad and different and
then we can kind of get into some of the
second and third order effects there
yeah I'd say what the Fed is done is
necessary
look 17 million people have lost their
jobs in the last three weeks the
expectations are that initial claims is
going to show another five million on
Thursday something's got to be done
about that you just can't sit there and
start spouting Austrian free-market
economics when you have that type of
level of unemployment now that I've said
that there is a real fear that what the
Fed is going to do is going to have
consequences on the backside all that
stimulus in other words taking 22
million people that are unemployed
handing them money and saying go out and
spend some of this yet all those
businesses that they were associated
with are not producing stuff but we've
got demand up I'm trying to define the
basic definition of inflation and then
I'm afraid not now not next quarter not
the quarter
as we go down but once the virus passes
and we go back up all that stimulus
could sparked off and into inflation
later on and I've heard a lot of people
say well the Fed is setting us up for
inflation yeah they may be but they
cannot and I don't think it would be
right for them to say look we might have
inflation in three quarters so all you
people have lost your job I'm really
sorry
good luck that you know you're stuck in
a bad position and finally if you will
the government forced everybody to go
Austrian Iranian the government forced
everybody close their business they
didn't do anything and then you know the
police came in and said you have to
close they're out compensation and maybe
this is the level of or the type of
compensation that their own either these
loans that will be forgiven in the
future or this unemployment benefits the
extra six hundred bucks a month that the
federal government's giving you on top
of whatever your state gives you as well
to because of you know those businesses
are not closed because of the failure of
those people that ran those businesses
unless you want to be brutal enough to
say that you should have had in your
business plan a pandemic that closes the
economy for three months which no-one
does nor nor nor should anybody have
that as well too so I do think what
they've done is necessary but I also
think it comes with a potential
consequence further down the line so it
isn't just all good and no bad there
might be a problem associated with it
later on and I think it was Jerome
Powell pretty explicitly said like look
I'm not worried about inflation at the
moment right it's kind of like let it
let us solve the problem at hand and
then maybe that comes later but we'll
deal with it at that point I do think
that part of the critique of the Fed has
been it doesn't matter how much
liquidity they pump into the market it
seems like it's not enough right this is
such a deflationary environment the
dollar continues to strengthen etc that
they will almost have to over rotate and
trillions and trillions of dollars get
injected into just the u.s. kind of
financial system but then you overlay
that with central banks around the world
doing that service on Japan with almost
a trillion dollar stimulus package etc
but at some point you do switch with
that deflationary environment back to
the inflationary environment right and
you almost get this like wave do you
think that there's a concern of like
hyperinflation or just higher levels of
inflation and so it's something that can
be controlled it's something to pay
attention to but it's not necessarily
something kind of ring the alarm about
or is this more of let's pound the table
and and actually be worried about some
sort of level of like hyperinflation or
something like that well I you know
let's put this in perspective I think
that in some levels what we're doing is
mmt version 1.1 you know modern monetary
theory and modern monetary theory always
has had the idea that you could borrow
lot higher levels of money because
there's you until you produce inflation
and that's when you would stop it so
we'll have to see a hyperinflation you
know I feel like that that step to step
one is look for 20 years we've been
talking about where's inflation and
other than a bump here there because
crude oil price is one over $100 it
hasn't been in evidence now maybe you
know I'll just be happy with the idea
that I'm not happy but I'll be satisfied
with the inflation call if we actually
see a bump up in inflation then the
question becomes okay the Fed has said
let me give you an example the Fed is
that this 2% inflation target a core PCE
since 2012 one month it's been above
that number you know seven or eight
years one month it's been above that
it's always been below it so now that
the Fed gets above it for three or four
months in a row okay finally got some
inflation at least we got that number up
what do they do about it do they start
mumbling average inflation target we
don't need to do anything let it run
Huck for a little while then I get a
little bit more worried that it's been a
go or do that the first signs of
inflation oh we got a tight we got to
start taking it back we got to start
pulling it back we'll have to see you
know we can all we can all speculate as
to what they would do when and if
inflation returns but as any general
knows every good battle-plan never
survives the first contact with the
enemy you know and so we'll see what it
looks like when when we're actually in
the war and see how they react to it for
sure and obviously the quantitative
easing is one part of the feds actions I
know
talked a little bit about kind of the
nationalization of markets and
industries etc maybe share kind of your
thoughts there yeah you know a lot of
people that follow the Fed would say to
me look they're buying commercial paper
both from the issuers in the market
they're buying corporate bonds both from
the issuers in the secondary market
they're buying ETFs how could the Fed do
that and the answer is they can't so how
they pulling this off and the answer is
the Treasury's buying this stuff each
one of those programs and there's nine
and total they've created a fund or a
special purpose vehicle with that
special purpose vehicle what they wind
up doing is the the fancy word the
Treasury the Fed uses the Treasury will
put at ten billion dollars in and being
a first loss position well I know what a
first loss position is that's the owner
I own my company when it takes a loss I
take the first loss that's what the Fed
is that's what the Treasury is the
Treasury is buying commercial paper the
Treasury is buying
corporate bonds the Treasury is buying
ETS that's the federal government the
Fed is providing the financing the Fed
can finance anything or borrow against
anything that has the Full Faith and
Credit of the United States government
well a special purpose vehicle funded by
the Treasury satisfies that so that's
how they're doing that
it's the Treasury that's buying them
that's why I say the Treasury is getting
involved in these markets and that
they're partially nationalizing the
markets there's one other important
point about that you're merging the Fed
and the Treasury together into one and
Powell's press conference last Thursday
three times he made a point of saying
every time they do one of these programs
they need the Treasury's permission
Steve minuchin works at the pleasure of
Donald Trump he needs Donald Trump's
permission Trump for a year and a half
has been blasting the Fed where's my
negative interest rates why aren't you
printing money if you had done all of
that we'd have the Dow 10,000 points
higher
well the Treasury the Fed just handed
over the printing press to Donald Trump
now
he's not gonna beYOU sit now everybody's
on the same page they gotta get these
programs up and running and I gotta do
something about those unemployed but I
heard rich clarity today say oh when the
time comes we the fed will know when to
pull back from these programs sorry
you gotta ask the guy in the Oval Office
whether or not it's time to pull back
and he might say no especially if you
think you're gonna do it in September
five weeks before an election or six
weeks before an election he's gonna know
guys you're turning those printing
presses up faster
I want my $10,000 so I could get
reelected that's the risk that they run
with this so it isn't the Fed that's
buying it it's the Fed is financing the
US government that's buying this and
that means that the political apparatus
has a say in monetary policy that that
that independence is not there another
argument for future inflation and as
well - yeah and we've obviously seen
this in kind of the dictator playbook
right a lot of third world countries
where somebody gets in charge they
basically get all the assets and they
say start printing and it hurts the you
know bottom fifty to seventy-five
percent of the population rich people
get rich and the dictator gets the
richest but at some point you run off
the cliff and you get some Bob while you
get Venezuela excetera one of the things
that I think is really interesting
they've covered and there's a fantastic
question is just like how do we stop the
programs right well what's the end of
these programs there's a lot of people
right now that are debating should we
have the program should we not how
should they be executed etc but there's
also the question of the end life of
them what's kind of your thoughts there
and maybe do you have suggestions as to
how they should be thinking about ending
these programs well I think the way that
you keep in mind we did a version of
this not as big in 2008 but the big
difference in 2008 was this was all new
no one really understood what was going
on with a lot of these programs a lot of
them are the same programs you know the
commercial paper funding facility is
exactly the same program and so we
didn't really know it and we said at the
time Ben Bernanke it's your baby man you
tell me one go when we
I will just do what you tell us to do
and Bernanke to his credit pulled back
on a lot of these programs before we got
the real inflation going fast forward to
2020 we now have and a better
understanding of how they work we have a
better feel for their meaning and we
have a president that has a different
view of the Fed remember when you had
Bush and Obama it was that you know Fed
independence is sacrosanct and we could
never tell the Fed what to do
Trump is fully ready to become Federal
Reserve Chairman right now and tell them
exactly what they should be doing and so
that's going to be the big problem I
think that if you know the way you
should pull back the programs is the way
that Bernanke did it is that we're gonna
do this for the minimum amount of time
just to get everything get it ceilings
and then get out but I feeling that
we're not we're gonna have to be pushed
further and further and the only thing
that's going to cause it to end I fear
is inflation comes back the markets riot
over the prospects of inflation and
demand that you stop with all the money
printing and all the inflationary
policies that they demand you stop them
at that point and once that happens I
think then you'll see the end of it but
then that's a painful exit what I just
argued it's not a pleasurable exit like
everybody wants to think it's going to
be I know the other argument that you'll
get is is the 2009 argument Oh will do
these programs for a while and then the
economy will recover and it will go and
then we can exit no one will care
because the economy's taking off
that was the QE argument from 2009 we're
gonna QE like crazy and then the economy
will take off and then will we exit no
one will notice
it's 2020 84 left but he never left they
did it for 13 years they tried to kill
me in 2013 and we had a temper tantrum
they tried to QE in the fourth quarter
or I'm sorry they tried to exit QE in
2013 in the market had a temper tantrum
they tried to exit in the fourth quarter
of 2018 the stock market fell 20% and
Paul had to completely reverse himself
an early night
team so what I'm afraid of is is that
this idea that you know the hand off
that the economy will recover and it
will be going guns and will just leave
and no one will notice because they're
so happy the economy's going and it
didn't work out the first time that they
tried doing it that way and I doubt
it'll work out this time as well too
yeah I always kind of explained this as
a crack addict right it's like hey it's
like a crack st. yah just one more hit
just one more hit right I promise I
won't do it again after this
but once the economy gets addicted to
the stimulus in you know I would
actually argue you can't get off of it
right it's impossible for them to leave
because literally you're now dependent
on that stimulus in order to keep going
and I guess really what this brings then
is as you get this merger between the
Federal Reserve the Treasury and
ultimately kind of the administration
what does that look like right like
let's say we get into a scenario that
you just described where the Federal
Reserve says hey based on our monetary
policy and The Economist and everything
like we actually think now's a good time
to pull back and it's kind of run its
course and we think that we've had the
impact that we can have the Treasury
then turns and says to the
administration hey what do you guys
think the administration says slam on
the gas right or at least don't let up
what is the process for kind of coming
to a agreement or some sort of
conclusion to that type of disagreement
between the Federal Reserve that's
supposed to have the independence and
then this you know organization that now
obviously wants control but but is it
necessarily supposed to have that
control right keep in mind now that when
I say they've merged they haven't merged
everything so the Fed you know is doing
more traditional QE where they're buying
Treasury securities and agency
securities they'd have the main over
that then it can pull back on that or
they could speed that part up as well
too but it's this alphabet soup of
programs they'll just have to negotiate
I think with the administration they'll
have to say you know I think it's time
that we pull back and then the
administration says no especially if you
believe like the consensus that you know
the virus will pass this summer it will
go away this summer the economy starts
you know rebounding this summer as we go
back to work and you're you're now in
the August
September or October and they start
making noise about pulling back and
Trump says I gotta get elected in four
weeks you know you're not pulling back
now you know and so then they start
going into that negotiation and then I
guess it really becomes a question of
how how insistent is the Fed going to be
about pulling back would they would they
end their traditional QE well we're not
gonna buy any more Treasuries that or
maybe we'll talk about raising rates now
I doubt they're gonna do any of that
because he even said on Thursday that
they're probably going to err on the
side of easy so it ultimately will come
down to the i-word inflation you're not
going to see it by the end of the year
because the economy is going to you know
I have a deflationary spot right now
like probably 21 22 is when you could
possibly see the inflation sprout back
and maybe force them out so I suspect
there'll be some behind-the-scenes
negotiations on this stuff and right now
like I said right now there's no problem
because all the treasury comes the Fed
comes to the Treasury and says we got to
do more Donnell do you think we should
do more yes yes yeah I don't even care
what the details are just do it do more
of it it was tweeting that he Lou's
tweeting it you know 12 months ago
exactly exactly so there's no there's no
disagreement now the disagreement comes
on the other side when it's Donald we
got to do less and I might add so he
said well what a fight becomes president
well you know one of the things that's
interesting about this program is you
know the old line that there's no
atheists in a foxhole there's no
capitalists in a crisis either and that
no less than Wall Street itself is just
applauding wildly what the Fed is doing
Bob Michael C global CEO of JPMorgan
Investment Management the Fed should
take over every market the Fed should
set the price of everything that's what
they want
Rick reader at Blackrock has been saying
the same thing
everybody has been cheering what the Fed
is doing now you know Biden comes in and
Biden then is asked the question
what do you think and you know in you
you know he turns to Glenn and Hodgins
or roger altman or all of his Democratic
moneybags you guys think we said
[ __ ] and those guys are gonna look
and go man I'm making a ton of money off
of buying paper and selling it to the
Fed at a premium no I think they should
keep going and what I'm trying to spin
here is there's just an easy underneath
the argument to be made that that
abiding administration will want this to
keep going as well too because there's
Manette's why Wall Street loves this
thing because they make so much money
off of it yeah I think part of what I've
tried to spend a lot of time educating
folks on is the reason why the rich
cheer when they see quantitative easing
is because they know how to benefit from
it right they understand get into the
assets the asset prices are gonna go up
this is gonna be fantastic we're all
gonna get rich and they're counting on
the bottom fifty plus percent not
understanding how money works not
understanding how quantitative easing
kind of eats away at the cash value and
ultimately those are the people who end
up losing and so I guess this brings a
question then of how far can the Fed go
right so you've got kind of on an amount
standpoint and then you also have do we
start to see them go into buying stocks
do they buy indexes do they actually
start playing kingmaker on individual
stocks like how far can these programs
go both in size and scope they can go as
far as they want I think what we got to
keep in mind let's talk about where
they're not going right now they've
pretty much done everywhere except
hotter yield they will by fallen angels
March 22nd they announced that they buy
corporate bonds and then they announced
on last week that they will now buy any
investment grade corporate bond that
lost its investment great status after
March 22nd so March 25th Ford got
downgraded to junk they're eligible for
the Fed to buy March 20th Occidental
Petroleum got downgraded to junk sorry
oxy you're not going to be blocked by
the Fed and so that's kind of where
they've drawn that line and they're not
buying equities why are they hesitant to
go there I think there's a simple reason
when you start owning high-yield
there's a very good chance that you're
gonna be involved in a restructuring
that's running the company that means
that one said about holder's thinks that
we should restructure the company this
way another set of bondholders thinks we
should restructure the company that way
hey said you own some of these bonds you
get a vote which way we're gonna go the
[ __ ] doesn't want to be in that place
and they don't want to be running
companies that's why they don't want to
own equities they don't want to have to
vote the slate of candidates for the
board of directors they will come under
enormous you know just to get the point
across if the Fed owns equities and then
it's our and then it's a proxy voting
season you can see AOC on the floor of
the house going I think I should have
you help you guys decide which directors
that these companies should be voting in
and that's why they don't want to go
there
so ETF's yes sure you could be involved
in the ownership of the fund management
company that manages ETF nobody cares
about that but you know could they lead
into buying spiders sure they could
bleed into that but I think it would be
a big leap for the Fed in order to buy
equities or go straight into high-yield
itself because then they're gonna get
into management companies I'm not
discounting that they won't do it I'm
just saying that I think that you know
I've argued on Twitter and stuff like
that I think it's a possibility that
they do it but first the SPS probably
got to make a new low offer below it's
March 23rd glow and they got a feel
under tremendous amounts of pressure
how far can they go you know money-wise
Paula said it and he's right boy they
they could put up a big infinite number
in front of that if they need to I think
more the question becomes will that work
because ultimately you got to ask the
question of Eric Peters one River asset
management wrote over the weekend if the
Fed eliminated all their programs the
stock market would probably fall 50% 50%
off its high it's down about a quarter
so it would go back to the below the
March 23rd gloves it's probably not
wrong on that meaning that the Fed is
artificially supporting the market at a
level it wouldn't be is
like to joke I'm pointing at my
Bloomberg right now if a little redhead
line came across my Bloomberg Jay Paul
changes his mind cancels all the
programs what do you think the stock
market would do tomorrow it beat down a
zillion points and so if the Fed is
holding the market it artificial levels
can it do it forever and I think the
answer is no I think they could do it
for a while because they've got a lot of
money with an infinite printing press
but ultimately whatever we perceive is
fair value and if that is lower that
weight will eventually come down on the
market and push it back down one more
time so yeah they could keep going and
they could keep trying but if the
markets at the wrong level even an
infinite printing press cannot keep it
there forever for a while yes but not
forever
yeah it almost feels like a lot of the
stock market movements right now are
pure speculation based on Federal
Reserve announcements and programs and
all this kind of stuff and almost like
selling the hope that hey they can get
us out of this but I do think that one
of the reality checks is gonna be that
first you know real big set of earnings
reports that come out where people show
you know hey our revenues down 70% right
and yeah our stock fell 25 percent but
that 25 percent haircut we took it we're
still overvalued based on the revenue
you have right and you start to get some
kind of you know at least an
acknowledgment or a highlight of the
dislocation between the speculation in
the markets versus the reality that a
lot of these companies and I was talking
to a buddy who's a an accountant been
doing it for a long time and he
literally said to me this morning he
goes I I haven't seen this level of
financial carnage that I've seen in the
last three weeks ever in my career right
he usually is dealing with kind of you
know small to medium-sized businesses
you know nothing kind of corporate or
public companies and so if that's what's
happening on the you know kind of
everyday Main Street you got to imagine
at some point that reality actually sets
in an investor's mind so what as well
yeah I agree
you know if you actually look at this
week yawn hot sees at goldman sachs and
mike wilson of morgan stanley basically
they abandoned their bearish calls
saying that the low is in place on march
23rd and the markets gonna go higher
reason one the feds ultimate pretty
so that's not like a fundamental reason
or the economy is getting better it's
just that you know if somebody keeps
hitting me in the face $100 bills enough
that maybe I'll change my behavior and
that's exactly what they're betting on
that that's going to happen it might
work at a strip club but I'm not sure it
works for the entire market in general
as well - and so that's what's really
pushing it as far as the carnage goes
you're right the Peter book fire I've
mentioned you gotta watch the balance
sheets and I think he's exactly right
for the following reason if your company
reports the 70% loss of revenue revenue
you are taking a giant loss and you
aren't losing capital you are not just
going to have a room revenue you're just
going to have a minute on your earnings
your capital position is going to be
impaired by that size of loss it's going
to affect the structure of your balance
sheet that takes a while to fix you know
because you're not going to have you
know like the old saying goes when we go
back you're not going to get two
haircuts and eat three dinners you know
those are gone and that revenue is not
going to be all replaced all at once so
you're gonna impair balance sheets and
that's going to create time in order to
see how long it's going to take and
that's what I think we got a watch in
this earnings report I think book first
got it right it's not that we're gonna
watch yeah we know the earnings numbers
are gonna be horrific but how much did
you impair the balance sheet I think
that's what your accountant friend was
talking about is that people's
businesses one under and they're drawing
against their life savings to keep them
going and they're at real risk of
financial ruin here even though
everybody says this will be temporary
and will go away and everything will be
okay
yeah but part of this really is it leads
into kind of the bailout conversation
right where if you are one of these
businesses whether you're a fortune 500
company or a small business you've got
to get that balance sheet to a position
of strength and so you can do that
through you know one of three things you
can either
inject more capital yourself somehow
pressure on the small business side or
you can go out to the equity and debt
markets right and I think that we're
starting to see some of that play out
obviously when it comes to bailouts you
know my whole position is really people
are going to the government cuz they
think the government's idiot in the room
right
you know United Airlines or whoever it
is
there's a market to be made in both debt
and equity it's just not at a price that
the executives want so they run to the
government and hope that the government
will give them you know better terms or
more advantageous terms but you are now
starting to see some of these companies
like today the airlines were announced
that they're in a conversation with Visa
MasterCard etc about potentially doing a
bulk sale of reward points right how do
they get cash in the door even if it's
at a discount for those points so that
they can start their strength in that
balance sheet and just feels like more
and more companies are gonna get put in
that position especially the longer that
this kind of economic crisis persists
absolutely I think that that's indeed
the case and I thought I found that I've
this fear that the ultimate superest
when we look back in this period was you
know the government is bailing out and
what are they everybody arguing is that
they're arguing that we need to have
warrants and the reason we need to have
warrants because everybody knows the
government's going to be a lot of these
companies and then their government's
going to make tons and tons of money off
of every single bailout so we need to
argue about the terms of the warrants
the terms of the greed and because the
last mail out we did worked out well for
some of the warrants as well that
doesn't mean that every one of these is
going to work this well as well so I
have a feeling that while they're dinner
go she ate how much money they think
they're gonna make off warrants these
fill up they're gonna wind up realizing
that maybe they don't make nearly as
much as they think they're gonna make
and it comes back to what you said it's
the terms you know there's an old saying
in the bond market that there are no bad
bonds there's only bad prices and if
you're going to give me financing at a
bad price you're not going to
advantageous to me bad for the lender
you're not gonna make money but I'm
gonna be very happy and what you did my
company will survive well because you
gave me cheap financing but your
warrants you're upside is that going to
be their car you're giving away to me
right now in the terms that you're
giving me in the financing yeah well
it's the difference between price takers
and price makers right there's some on
either side of that you've previously
said that we're kind of been like a Bear
Stearns moment but maybe not the Lehman
moment talk a little bit about kind of
how what you mean by that first of all
and then second of all what does that
mean in terms of moving forward out of
of where we are today so um let me talk
about it as a technical analyst one of
the things I should have mentioned at
the top is I have a chartered market
technician I was in the second class the
1998 got my murdered Market Technicians
designation CMT we have done a 50 50%
retracement in this market and if you go
back and you look at bear bear markets
29 37 62 2073 for 2000 2008 50 %
retracements happen all the time you
retrace have to move everybody thinks
it's over and then you roll over and go
down you had a low in the market in
March of Oh 8 and then we bailed out
bear stearns and by may of o8 we did a
50% retracement that's it it's over we
bailed out bear stearns the markets
recovered half of what it needs to
recover it's done there's no more crisis
and the second quarter GDP numbers were
originally reported as positive one and
a half percent see proof it's all over
they got revised to minus something or
another and then we had the Lehman
moment in the fall and that's where I
think we are like March 23rd was it it's
over the Fed came in unlimited the
markets recovered it's done it's done
it's done and then we find up rolling
over and going back down one more time
that's what I meant by the bear moment
is that typically the low the Marshall 9
low was made on despair there's nothing
more we could do the markets just
destined to keep falling forever and
ever and it was almost to the point
where when the market did start to lift
off in mid-march of o.9 everybody's
first reaction to that was not it's a
buying opportunity but this is like a
cruel joke
it can't be going up there's so many
problems and stuff and then that was
indeed the start of a bull market so I
do think that's kind of where we are
right now we've had you know the March
23rd low we've had the Fed all-in we had
the 50% retracement we had Bear we had
it bailed out we had the 50% retrace but
everybody was arguing that's it it's all
done with and in fact we've got just
like we had no way we got the analysts
today now all changing their opinion
that March 23rd was the law yeah it
feels like the economy cannot recover
with us all sitting at home that's all I
keep going back to right it's just like
look how are you gonna argue that the
economy is recovering if we're all still
sitting at home you know it can in
overtime it can create efficiencies that
we didn't have before now like I said if
you get the sniffles or if you've got if
you want to take half a day off you
could zoom into your office for one or
two days that's great
the reason we didn't do it before is
everybody said in theory we can do it
but nobody wanted to go through this the
blood sweat and toil of trying to figure
out how to make it happen well listen
now figured out how to make it happen
so that could be good but you're right
the bigger issue is if we're all going
to sit at home and we're all gonna try
and educate our kids in the other room
at home this is our economy is not built
that way
if that's what we have to do we have to
fundamentally restructure it we don't
want to fundamentally restructure it so
this is not going to work in the long
term but it could be a nice legacy once
we go back to normal that you know any
time you need to bail out in the office
for one or two days you've got this new
tool to kind of keep you connected and
not just completely loose loose tag
touch with it like we did before the
virus yeah before we move on to a couple
other topics last question around the
Fed is you know there's a lot of people
saying that this isn't capitalism right
and obviously you said earlier about how
kind of there's no capitalism in a
crisis talk a little bit about how you
see the the incentive structure changing
right if I take risk and I know that the
government always bail me out I'll take
all kinds of crazy risk right it's like
a no-lose situation it's the best way to
make money because I can't lose that
doesn't seem like a very sustainable
strategy so maybe talk a little bit how
incentives change after we see this type
of quantitative easing and bailouts etc
you're right that this isn't capitalism
and you know I think what we need to
remember by capitalism is the Joseph
Schumpeter argument of creative
destruction and that I also think that
the problem with capitalism is so many
people don't understand capitalism
you know I remember 2012 presidential
election and that the battlecry was bin
Laden was dead and GM was alive and what
they meant by GM was alive is to this
day everybody still thinks that
bankruptcy and restructuring means that
a company ceases to exist
that they don't understand the idea of
restructuring that if we had let you
know just to use the autos 409 because
we've got 10 years of history to look at
if we had let the auto companies go
bankrupt that somewhere in Detroit
there'd be a half ton car on an assembly
line with weeds growing through the
floor that would have never happened
those assets would have been spun off
they would have been restructured they
would have come in as a GM they would
come in as other companies as well -
they would have become a lot more
efficient I think what we did with the
bailouts of the auto industry is while
we bailed out the auto industry we kept
it stuck where it is now so that it
opened the door for a company like a
Tesla now yeah we can argue Tesla's a
bubble and stuff but they have really
been in the forefront of leading the
innovation in the auto industry between
electric cars manufacturers selling and
everything else in a way that the auto
companies itself could never do if they
are if they are incentivized to not
think boldly and not creatively to
change themselves so in the long run
we're better off letting companies
become these organic things that Bend
and fold and become something different
and the like that and that is where we
should be in the long term but we don't
think that way we always think in the
very short term you know that's been my
complaint about what's going on with
this virus right now when I listen to
Wall Street all they want to talk about
is what's gonna happen the next two
quarters you know it's gonna be really
bad second course for us bad third
quarter yeah I get that let's move on
what's gonna be a long trip now it's
gonna be I just I can't go I can't think
past September 30th is well all that I
just want to know when we're gonna
restart and one things are gonna get
less bad and that is that
that kind of short-term thinking is what
leads to these bailouts and while it may
give you pleasure through the end of the
year when you look back at it in five
years or ten years you say look at these
industries that should have been
innovating and should have been changing
but you've incentivized them to
basically status quo and that doesn't
help anybody in the long run
yet it's it's interesting that the
industries that are asking for bailouts
tend to all look the same right Airlines
auto industry etc one thing that we saw
today is the I guess the Governors
Association or something like that has
come forward and they're asking for
about half a trillion dollars about five
hundred million dollars in bailout money
for their states so now you have state
governments going to the federal
government asking for them to bail out
bail it out what I continue to say is
there's a lot of financial ramifications
from this right but this specific
development to me is gonna lead to
individuals saying wait a second why are
you taking 25 30 35 40 45 percent of my
income if you guys can just print the
money and basically just hand it to
yourselves right and write what why is
their taxes and all of these structures
that you know look there's plenty of
people in kind of a small community that
they hate taxes they hate the government
whatever I'm not talking about those
people I'm talking about the average Joe
or Jane on you know kind of Main Street
business and an employee of business
saying wait why am i giving you you know
a significant portion of my income and
then you guys just go print it and stick
it in your your your bank accounts and
that's your revenue when you run out of
money it just feels like there's
something other than the ramification on
the financial industry and it's more
societal in nature so I don't know if
you have any thoughts there yeah you
know you starting to hear people grumble
that too I mean it hasn't quite happened
but if the Fed could just if the Fed
could print four or five trillion
dollars without there being any
consequence no inflation no consequence
well why do I pay taxes why do I pay
taxes at all why don't they just print
it up and let it go from there and then
you know what the inflation well there
isn't any right now and as far as the
municipal ago
are we all in a hundred percent
agreement that the average state
financing is a complete mess between
their pension plans and their union
contracts and everything else that
states have had that especially when you
get to the municipal level especially
the big city municipal levels if you
look at Chicago or Detroit or New York
or Los Angeles or take your pick that
it's all messed up and that may be a
catalyst from this could be the creative
change that we need to fix some of these
problems now those problems won't get
fixed without a little bit of pain but
to continue this busted system that
creates a lot of pain for the taxpayers
there's a model there's a lot of middle
income and lower middle income taxpayers
that live in urban areas that are really
being taxed to death to pay for all of
this inefficiencies that everybody
agrees it would be nice if it went away
well here's your opportunity here's your
catalyst that you've always needed to
force that change instead you just want
the Fed to print money and throw it at
you so you could continue the status quo
I think that's a lost opportunity to fix
some of these problems and they need to
be they need to be dealt with us look
I'm in Chicago on the pension plan in
the pension system here it's so woeful
II screwed up that something needs to be
fixed with that as well too but you know
we're just hoping and praying that the
Fed just prints the money so that
everything can stay the way it is broken
that's the way it is now just continue
to keep it broken yeah one of my
favorite things to tell people is I love
when everyone says let's take the money
from the billionaires and I say hold on
a second so you want to take the money
from the people who have shown a
propensity to be a good capital
allocator and give it to the people who
suck at cap or allocating right let's go
give it to the government and see what
inefficiency they can do with that
capital it seems kind of more
destructive than anything right and you
know if you've seen the studies but if
you took the Forbes 400 and you took all
their money and let's say all their
money and of course that means you have
to liquidate Microsoft and you have to
liquidate Amazon and not to mention the
damage that that would cost you could
fund the government for about a month
okay now that you've now that you've
wiped out all the
there's and you got through the month of
May what are you doing June and now we
don't have Amazon and we don't have
Microsoft we don't have Facebook anymore
cuz you're liquidated it to pay for me
so I think that people also way under
estimate overestimate the number of
billionaires in the sheer amount of
money that they have you know they have
eventually they have way more than you
or me could possibly imagine
but collectively as a group compared to
the size of the government it's not that
big yeah I was a little bit about
globalization or the lack thereof and
obviously this idea that the virus is
probably going to reverse the trend of
globalization I think that there was
this kind of underlying tone of hey
borders coming down you know let's be
more global both on a business and also
a social component virus happens now
everyone's basically walking around with
masks on pointing at each other saying
you know forget another country hey
you're from another state right I heard
those New Yorkers they got a ton of
virus over Chicago oh no I don't want
you coming from that city maybe talk a
little bit about how that that trend
reversal globalization maker yeah you
know another state the people the
suburbs are telling the people in New
York or Chicago to go back to the city
at this point well yeah as far as
globalization goes the virus came out of
out of China you know we could leave for
another argument whether or not China
did everything that they needed to do
and it's been properly reporting
probably not and there's a lot of anger
around the world rick scott senator from
florida was on TV last week and he got
very mad and he said anybody who buys
anything made in china is immoral well
you know 60 days ago you would have been
run off as a kook if you would have said
that and as I like to say who's gonna
defend China you know there's 22,000
dead Americans is any budding Democratic
Party gonna stand up and say Rick you've
lost your mind
how about Europe is McCrone from France
he's got 16,000 dead is he gonna say no
we have to be nice to the Chinese no I
the Italians gonna say that no who's
this is global who's going to say that
Larry Kudlow over the weekend Easter
Sunday said remember Larry Kudlow who
signed off his show I believe in free
market capitalism is the best path to
prosperity said the United States
government should pay the moving costs
of all companies that want to move back
from China um ok two things about that
we're study free market capitalism Larry
but more importantly so now we're ready
to do they come the other direction and
I think that there's going to be a lot
of that everybody's in agreement then at
a minimum some strategic stuff like
pharmaceutical should be coming back ok
why does it stop there why are we going
to now turn to mr. cook and say why are
you leaving yourself vulnerable by
making your phones in China why aren't
you making your phones here or in Europe
or in South America or a little bit of
all and mr. cooks argument would be
because it's more efficient to make them
in China and we would come back to them
and say this is about resiliency now
this is not about efficiency anymore
that era has sailed we're more about the
resilient era then next time we have to
shut down a bit cover the economy for
three months we want nobody to have a
bailout okay think about how the balance
sheets have to look and how everybody's
business has to be straight they can be
structured for that but they they're
they're not going to give you that
forward p/e of 20 on a hundred thirty
earrings to get you back to thirty four
hundred on the SP you're not going to
have that so I think that that deep
globalization is going to push back and
the governments are going to do that too
when people start pointing at the Trump
administration you could have done more
or the Johnson administration in the UK
you could have done more they're gonna
say it's China's fault and everybody's
going to say yeah I agree with you it's
China's fault and so and there's going
to be no natural constituency to defend
China so I do think you're going to see
some of that the globalization come down
and it's going to you know it's going to
mean less efficiency I didn't make a
qualification of whether that's good or
bad it might be necessary but it is a
reality that the reason we're in China
is it's more efficient and if we leave
we're going to be a little less so yeah
when
happens what do you think occurs in
terms of the China verse us global
superpower showdown right and what I
mean by that is you're essentially doing
is by becoming more resilient you're
becoming less efficient and therefore
can you actually produce the goods as
well
probably not can you produce them as
fast probably not as cheaply definitely
not and so you get in this weird world
where do US consumers exclusively
consume then from US companies where
everything's made in the US and China is
exclusive Chinese manufacturers that are
all made in China
or do you still get the consumer kind of
shopping for lowest price and kind of
benefiting from the efficiencies but
companies are the only ones that are
affected and they're the ones that are
forced to be resilient and therefore US
companies end up actually losing because
they lose that efficiency yeah I think
you know first of all that efficiency or
that resiliency will come over time it
won't happen immediately you know we
won't just wholesale pull out of China
we will start to pull out of China over
time I think from the Chinese
perspective they're gonna be under
enormous pressure because they're going
to see their growth rates peak and
they're going to start coming down keep
in mind the following about China in the
United States there's nine cities that
have a million or more population and
there's ten cities in Europe that have a
million or more population in China
there's over 30 and we learned a new one
called Wuhan that had more people than
New York City probably before November
nobody knew what one was as well there's
1.4 billion people in China every year
the population of Canada about 22
million people in China migrated from
the farms in the rural areas which are
really third-world to the cities which
are really first world in China there's
modern is any city and they're looking
for a job and as long as China's growing
fast they could bring those people and
then show up sometimes with no shoes on
and they say here sit down at this thing
and do this like this for you know for
fourteen wine a day and you can send it
back to your family
the farm and they're happy to do it now
they come to the city you don't have
that growth rate anymore and they don't
have that and there's going to be
resentment and anger and they pile up in
the ghettos in these cities and they get
mad why don't I have a job and they
create a lot of social unrest in China
so China is going to be under the gun to
try and rectify this now the way that
China is going to rectify this I think
is real simple is chuckling needs to be
more transparent let the world in let
the world see what's going on the next
time
three people have a coffin China people
from the West can go down and see is
this a pandemic or is this nothing
instead of waiting for you to give me
you know your spin and hide it the
Chinese government's never communist
governments never going to do that so
they're gonna have some change on this
flip side we're gonna have that change
too we're gonna have to see us pull back
while we pull back I think it's going to
fall on the companies themselves in
order to eat that loss their margins are
going to have to get squeezed over time
it will be only be as the process is
unfolding is that you're going to see
then then be able to pass those class
long because remember I think what's
going to happen is companies are going
to be forced to become more resilient
there's going to be rules there's going
to be twisting of arms you got to get
out of China or something like that and
then they're going to get out of China
but then they always won't be the lowest
cost producer but they're gonna have to
be forced to price to the lowest cost
producer and that's going to make them
squeeze their margins and as well - so
this will be a process that will take
some time and again I'm not suggesting
that this is catastrophic in any way but
what I am suggesting is if you're
waiting for 15% earnings growth in 24
word Pease to just power the market
forever and ever that error may have
ended already and we're going into a
different type of era it doesn't mean
the stock market goes you know down 90
percent like the Great Depression but
we're not going to go back to the old
highs for a while at least one cycle
before
kind of figure it out yes this kind of
leads to the conversation of what
happens or what can people do moving
forward right and basically the
situation right now is from this
deflationary environment we're getting
tons of liquidity injected around the
world into the financial system will
eventually move into that inflationary
environment and as we saw in 2008 to
2011 you know take something like gold
gold went down almost 30% in the summer
of 2008 and then all of a sudden it ends
the entire crisis up about 300% hits an
all-time high in 2011 1 do you think we
see a similar kind of sequential you
know playbook here with something like
gold or do you see something different
happening even though we're likely to
get that inflation at some point in the
future and I'm assuming that investors
will look for those inflation hedge
assets yeah gold is a tough one to
measure you know I've always struggled
with it I think that in this era you
know people have always said to me I
can't believe what the Fed is doing why
isn't the dollar
crashing and my answer is have you seen
what the ECB individually they're
printing even faster than we are
and then their answers why isn't gold
going up and I always argued very good
question I'm kind of myself surprised
that gold hasn't responded more
positively I think the reason Gold is
not responding is what is got supposed
to represent for the investor it's a way
supposedly to get your money out of the
financial system but it's not really out
of the financial system besides most
people buy gold they buy they buy GLD or
they buy gold futures how does you bind
you deed listed in the new york stock
exchange you're just buying a Tesla
version of gold is all your wine what
you need to do is buy coins and burying
them in your backyard well that's too
hard
the dealers are running out by the way
the premium spot gold over like the
Comex price is about a 10 or 12 year
wide it is that that's when what's been
happening also gold becomes a source of
funds when you are in it when you are in
a stressful period and the markets
falling and there's margin costs being
hit you've got this one asset he
that hasn't lost value that you might
need to liquidate in order to meet your
margin calls in other places that you've
lost money and I think that that's what
gold is suffering from and I think it
did a no.8 and that's why I think not
surprisingly gold made its peak at 1900
in 2011 it was a year and a half after
the crisis so I think it will lag again
as it goes higher but the biggest thing
about gold you have to remember is if
you're buying gold because you think
that inflation is coming or bad things
are going to happen to the financial
system if you're buying something listed
on the New York Stock Exchange in GLD
you're not getting out of the financial
system and that is the problem that gold
has right now it's still part of the
whole system as well it's not as
separate as people like to make it out
to be yeah and and I guess really this
all kind of brings us to the point of
have you heard Brent Johnson's dollar
milkshake theory I've heard of it yes
okay so basically his whole idea is
essential banks around the world inject
liquidity into the financial system
they're essentially making a milkshake
right there kind of everyone's throwing
their liquidity in to this cup but only
one asset gets to have the straw or that
that asset sucks all the value into it
and his theory is the dollar milkshake
so obviously if the dollar is that acid
that gets to hold the straw and we're
having all that liquidity ultimately
seek out the dollar and so what you see
around the world is the dollar strength
and the other currencies are selling off
or losing value against the dollar you
see other assets you know cross market
selling off and the dollar continues to
strengthen and you know kind of a
classic deflationary environment what
I'm wondering is does this help to
accelerate kind of that the
strengthening of the dollar and then
ultimately the the need for the
weakening of it will this accelerate
people looking to get outside the system
right does this drive people to gold to
crypto to to other things where they
feel like they're getting out of the
system or is that more something
simultaneous that happens but is it
necessarily a driver of that action yeah
I think the first part of Brent's got a
ride that then everybody's racing to the
dollar and they're racing and a dollar
for two reasons reason one
one everything remember now let's
remember that the dollar is the reserve
currency what that means is ninety
percent of world trade is in dollars we
quote the price of crude oil in dollars
we float the price of gold in dollars if
you are Chinese and you want to do a
trade for Brazilian timber you're
quoting the price and paying for it in
dollars is what you're doing most of the
time maybe in rare exceptions don't
accept one or the l'entrée al but the
most of the time it's always done in
dollars so the world needs dollars for
two reasons one is because there's trade
that they the economies have slowed
their trade is down then they need to
get their economies going so they need
to amass dollars especially the Chinese
they want to restart their economy well
they gotta buy crude oil they gotta buy
copper they gotta buy aluminum they
gotta buy wood they need dollars for
that so they're trying to acquire
dollars for it the second thing that
reason everybody wants dollars is when
you get into a crisis everybody looks
around and goes what currency do I want
to be in and the answer is I want to be
in the reserve currency I want to be in
dollars so I've had this argument with
people in Europe I can't believe that
the dollar is going up why do you think
that we want to run the euros when
there's a problem what do you know I
want because ultimately if I want to buy
crude oil if I want to buy a copper I
still go back to dollars for it as well
so that is why I think there's this
giant need for dollars the safe haven
currency and because it's the thing that
we do trade with - your second question
well will this accelerate the need or
the desire for people to find another
reserve currency I think they've been
desperately looking for one for 10 years
I think you know to quote Winston
Churchill the dollars the worst for
reserve currency we've ever devised
except for every other one and so it
benefits that there is no alternative
you're not going to you know wave a wand
and say the Euro or the yen or the or
the pound or the one none of those can
fill the bill that the dollar fills I've
argued that in theory
the next reserve currency will be a
crypto for a hot second I thought maybe
Libre would do it but then I thought for
sure I was onto something because the
first thing that they did when they
announced Libre was they dragged Marcus
in front of Congress and ripped him a
new one cuz they were afraid of what
Libre represented so I'd like to say
that the next currency will be a crypto
it probably doesn't exist yet I don't
know what you know when it will exist in
which one it will be because it needs to
be both a medium of exchange and a store
of value
well Bitcoin might be a store of value
but it's not a real good medium of
exchange maybe there's some others like
ether or something like that you could
argue our better medium of exchange but
they're not a good store of value so
we're on the path for it I've used the
analogy of if you remember early on in
the search engines we used to have Lycos
and then that went bankrupt we had
almost a Vista that won bankrupt but we
had the idea we were one of these guys
is going to be a really good search
engine one day then we got Yahoo and it
became the fastest company become an S&P
500 company we thought that was it then
we got Google and then everything
changed well we're waiting for the
Google of Kryptos to show up and we're
probably somewhere in the light goes off
to Vista era on our way to the Yahoo era
before we get to Google and then I think
that that would be the reserve the new
reserved curtsy and I don't think that
the next reserve currency will be some
government controlled crypto I think it
will be outside of their weech is what
it is where it would go there's no
reason to have a government controlled
with crypto takeover you've got the
dollar and you can mean you know and the
Fed could make you a digital dollar in a
week if you wanted that but it's still
the dollar
it hasn't changed anything so I do think
it's coming but it still could be many
years down the road right now maybe it
exists in some infancy form right now
whichever crypto is going to be it or
maybe it's still to be invented yeah
this is super juicy I mean this is
parlor I want to talk to you because I
think that you are at what I'll call the
tip of the spear of an emerge
group on Wall Street and kind of the
traditional financial system in that if
you would have this conversation five
years ago anybody in nutritional
financial system would be like you're
crazy thinking that one of these digital
currencies is going to be potentially in
the future of reserve currency now I
think what we get is exactly the
position that you're stating which is
hey actually there's a very high
probability that the next reserve
currency will be a crypto I just either
one don't know which one it is or two
don't think it's been created yet right
so I think that like that group is
actually was not exist in five years ago
now there's a number of people and is
actually going pretty quickly the people
who kind of fall in that bucket of their
belief the one thing that I keep going
back to so a lot of times I'll hear kind
of the light goes Yahoo Google or some
variation of you know the first thing
doesn't always win but I'd love to hear
your thoughts on like the only thing
that I usually go back to is like
currency is a little bit different in
that it's kind of like if you're sitting
there in Venezuela or Zimbabwe and your
governments currency fails when they
then say hey just kidding here's our
second currency that we just created you
almost have lost trust in the government
monitoring the currency right like
you're not gonna then take all your
wealth and say okay the you know Bolivia
our failed let me put this in like
Bolivia rv2 right you're just like no
you guys are idiots I'm not gonna risk
my wealth here when it feels to me like
digital currencies or in that same
bucket and what I mean by that is
Bitcoin was the first it's the most
popular is the most liquid large market
cap excetera
what I wonder is if Bitcoin doesn't
become the global reserve currency if it
doesn't end up being the winner do
people say well there was one why do I
trust version two three four five six
seven you know ten or twelve and what I
don't know yet is is it true that
currencies are different than let's say
technology companies or other products
or actually it's all the same and people
would be willing to kind of jump from
crypto to crypto until they found that
one that ended up being the winner no I
think that's a good point I think that
you know could Bitcoin be it I think
what Bitcoin needs to do you probably
know this better than me is it needs to
be a medium of exchange and I think the
blockchain is not quite ready
have you know several tens of thousands
of transactions a second to be able to
handle it in that degree but I do think
that what a global cryptocurrency gives
people that they would immediately
embrace no matter how many failures
there is is this idea that my government
can't devalue Aroon my wealth it can by
having it in an encrypted account they
can't get at it because one of the other
things I think is going to happen if you
ever got a global cryptocurrency
governments would have to change the tax
structure they can't tax you an income
anymore because they can go ahead and
audit you and you know and I can handle
my my thumb drive and guess what it's
it's 256 K encrypted and you ain't
breaking into it and as far as you know
even though I have a 14 bedroom house
and six Ferraris on the driveway
I have zero income so you can't tax me
on that so what I think they'll move to
is a use tax and they'll just say you
know every stop thousand square-foot in
your house you're gonna pay this for a
tax every car you have you gonna pay
that for text I don't care what your
income is and that's the way that the
governments will have to survive but
people will sell like that because I'll
say my money is safe if my government
does stupid things I don't lose the
value of my money like they like they
have in all those other countries so I
think if you can offer that promise of a
safe store value that's beyond the reach
of profligate governments I think that
it would be embraced whether it's an
existing crypto that can morph itself
into that or some new one as well too so
there are operational difficulties with
it so yeah I hear what you're saying
that it might be different but I don't
know if if Bitcoin is really graduated
beyond the speculation point no one is
really trying to use that is anything
but a speculation right now and we'll
have to see what happens I think that's
one of the problems with the crypto is
right now instead why aren't they
rallying in the financial crisis because
of my probably money Bitcoin I can't do
anything with it until I change back to
dollars and then buy groceries
and so I'm still kind of stuck in the
same system that I'm trying to get out
of at the same time and I think that
that's one of the reasons that they're
struggling to get out of the way kind of
the same argument I made with gold but
once you get one where you could say I
can take this currency and I just don't
mean you can buy a ticket on cheap
flights but I could actually do
something real with it outside of the
financial system then you've got
something and you've really got
something going you know yeah well
minimus I could do it that would really
be the game changer at that point yeah I
think one of the things that you're
really highlighting here right and some
of the stuff you said I agree with some
of it you know I have other thoughts as
to how it happens but but I think it's
less important for the main point of
like this separation of state and money
right and if you would have talked about
this ten years ago I mean you're the
anarchist of anarchist and literally
people would have thought you were crazy
now I think again going to kind of that
mainstream population though there's a
lot of people saying wait a second
actually sounds interesting explain that
to me right and they don't necessarily
care so much about like show me the
answer today or the solution but you've
highlighted a problem that I have
identified is a problem right and I
think what ends up happening is over you
know months and years and and you know
even decades you get more and more
people that buy into this idea of like
I'd be okay with the separation of state
money if the money was a good store of
value was a good medium of exchange and
that's not just a financial markets
thing right they're also seeing hey I
get you go to Starbucks and use my
reward points and I just use mobile
payments like what do I care if that's
dollars Starbucks points or you know
crypto I get it go on the video games
and my kid is using be bucks and you
know all these different things that I
think kind of societally are occurring
or just training people or educating
people on the idea of a digital asset
and then all of a sudden you get that
separation and again it's very slowly
right you get a couple of people at
first and they kind of slowly cross over
and it's not even with a hundred percent
of their well if that's the other thing
right it's like hey I'm gonna take 1% of
my wealth okay now I'll take 5% then 10
and 20 then 30% and then eventually you
get to the point where it kind of flips
over and everyone says well duh why did
we ever not have
separation of state money but I'm not up
the belief like that's gonna happen
tomorrow either right and I think the
catalysts were there was the 2008 nine
bailouts I think that the bailout those
bailouts I think that there there's
there's something interesting about the
bailouts that they the catalyst for them
I think of you know led to the
resentment which was Occupy on the
laughed it was the Tea Party on the
right it led to the polarization that
we've seen in our politics and it's not
just here you know it's brexit in the UK
and stuff and so there's that distrust
of the government that was being
fostered that can be accelerated right
now
even though we're doing paycheck
protection plans and all this other
stuff if the perception is at the end of
the day that the wealthy are being cared
for and that everybody else is not being
cared for as well that that could really
start pushing this idea that that we
need to separate money from the
government because the government
doesn't take care of us being the middle
class or the broad population it just
takes care of this select elite
pretending like they're trying to take
care of us and so you can definitely see
that and I think you're absolutely right
I think also ten years ago if you talked
about a digital currency most people
didn't know how that was supposed to
work but now you know I got my I got my
Apple watch right here now and I know
how to waive that and everybody knows
how to do that stuff and now if you tell
them okay you just do this thing with
some of their currency I know how to do
that I'm comfortable doing that I'm
comfortable waving my phone in front of
a reader in order to pay something so
we're starting to get that mentality you
know to come down the pike as well too
and we're moving that way very fast and
interestingly you probably know when it
comes to digital payments the United
States is pretty much behind a lot of
countries especially if you look at
m-pesa in Kenya some third world
countries are way ahead of us in digital
payments I know I tell my friends this
they can't believe that ya know there
there's a grant there's this there's a
little village in in
and there's a Honda generator of
charging 50 phones and tomorrow these
guys that are pushing oxidants are
transferring money with their phones
back and forth to each other
more than we do with our iPhone at
Starbucks right now so we're way behind
a lot of countries when it comes to
digital payments so it could wind up you
know that that reserve currency thing we
could be the laggard in that if you're
waiting for the American psyche to catch
up on it look the rest of the world
psyches well on the road further on the
road than we are right now yeah I always
joke I think I was maybe a year ago now
or so there was a conference in Russia
and Putin was up there and he in no
uncertain terms said the dollar is
expensive and I want to find an
alternative right and basically was just
like I want to get off this and so we
know that you know other superpowers
would love to be the owner of the
reserve currency or have an alternative
that the USS and control but I also
think that there's a lot of people who
aren't necessarily other superpowers
that they believe the same thing before
we finish up I was asked to two
questions and then you get asked me one
to finish what is your favorite book or
the most important book that you've ever
read the most important book that I've
ever read boy that's a good question
there's a there's a lot of ones but I
would have to say I'll answer the
question by the the book that really had
a profound impact on me reminiscence of
a stock operator I read it when I was in
college it made me understand the psyche
of speculation it made me it attracted
me to the fixed income markets or excuse
me to the financial markets I'm in the
fixed income market and that was kind of
like the the book I I took a Clyde took
a finance class my friends professor
recommended it is outside reading and
boy it just completely changed my life I
love it it's great answer
second question aliens are you a
believer or not think they're real oh
yeah I do think they're real I do think
that at a minimum you've probably got
alternate forms lower forms of life
bacteria and stuff like that whether or
not there is intelligent alien life
forms I
you think they're real are they floating
around incognito in this on this planet
I do love sci-fi but I'll go with no on
that question yeah they're still stuck
in their solar system and we're stuck in
ours yeah I think that's probably a a
pretty safe bet is if I if I had to bet
that'd take same thing what one question
you have for me to to finish up um what
is opening day since you got a Yankees
can't lose
I actually am of the belief they are
going to all sports it's not just
baseball but all sports are going to
start playing without fans in the stands
for some period of time
my guess is baseball we start to see
that earliest end of May latest like
beginning of July maybe maybe somewhere
in that range and I have no clue what
that means in terms of this I mean
you're not going to play a full season
right so I like kind of what did what do
they end up doing I have no clue but but
uh I'll interject on that one phrase
since we're talking about baseball for
five seconds if you see the plan that
they've got that they would play with no
fans to make it more cost-efficient and
everything they would play it in Arizona
that they would have all the teams in
Arizona that way when they have to do an
away game it's a twenty minute bus ride
down the road to another minor league
stadium because you don't need a stadium
for 50,000 as well so and they move all
the florida minor league teams to
Arizona as well too but bear in mind
because I'm a big baseball fan too only
25% of the revenue comes from TV there
if you're still gonna pay Bryce Harper
38 million dollars a year and you're
losing me on the gate you're gonna take
a big hit to have him on your team yeah
I think part of this is what do you do
like there's a lot of ramifications like
what do you do if you're playing at a
minor-league baseball stadium and now
somebody breaks the homerun record right
and people could say all day long you
know hey it was so baseball it may be
also I saw a plant what we do
right yeah and then I saw playing at one
point that they were going multiple
players had said that they were willing
to play double headers multiple times a
week till I catch up on games and I was
like yeah they say that now and they're
sitting on their couch but they get you
know six weeks into playing three to
four double headers a week and they're
just like dude what are we doing you
might wonder saying that because the
Players Association is agreed to get
paid pro rata so if they're gonna go
play 81 games they're only get half
their pay so yeah let's double up cuz I
want to get 162 games and I want to get
paid but the owners are not gonna want
it because they're you know like I said
three quarters of their revenue is you
playing in front of 40,000 people at
Yankee Stadium at Wrigley Field and if
you're just broadcasting it locally on
TV on the YES Network or on the new
marquee network for the Cubs you're not
gonna be making enough money to pay
those 200 million dollar payrolls is
what they're gonna wind up having happen
so it's gonna be a tough what bull is a
little different because they make more
than half their revenues off of TV so
they could play those in empty stadiums
and as television content and probably
get by a lot more implicit doesn't start
until September and we should be in a
different point with the with the virus
back then as well - yeah for sure it's
gonna be interesting to watch play out
listen Jim I really appreciate taking
the time to do this where can people
find you on the internet and also go
find other research you guys cranked out
so the best place would be my twitter
feed at Bianco research or our website
Bianco research comm but I would start
with our Twitter feed as well toward
look me up and LinkedIn if you're on
LinkedIn those are the two on the social
platforms that I traffic most frequently
you've been doing a fantastic job on
Twitter and how they recommend people to
follow you so see if we get you some
followers there but listen thank you so
much and also a huge shout out to Nick
prints from coinbase for helping set
this up we wouldn't do it without him so
I appreciate his help and I want to do
this again in the future thank you